it's only a journey the length of a
football field to cross the border from
Turkey to Greece here but it's an almost
impossible one in a Smuggler's boat
there is also a land border which the
Syrian refugees managed to cross a few
days ago soon they were deported back to
Turkey they remain undeterred the Greek
soldiers took our phones our money and
our bags I went back to Istanbul packed
up my bags and returned this riverbank
in the village of Doron has become a
campground of hope these families look
at the merge River and see all the
possibilities Europe represent Syrian
refugees dia his wife and three young
children have used branches donated
blankets and tarps to build a shelter to
shield against the unrelenting cold wind
day and night for four days we need to
take a breath I'm 34 years old and I've
seen nothing good maybe my children can
see something good we need some space to
see our future the UN refugee agency
UNHCR says countries must not use
excessive or disproportionate force
against migrants they must process
asylum applications in an orderly manner
and the international community needs to
increase its support of Turkey the
country is home to almost 4 million
refugees three point seven of them are
Syrian a few kilometers away the
European Council President and the Greek
Prime Minister visited the border we
have not used the time wisely since the
last migration crisis to address the
situation effectively it's about time
that we do it now during nine years of
war Syrians have heard similar
pronouncements and promises from world
leaders before dia and other refugees
we've been talking to tell us this isn't
simply about turkey opening its borders
to Europe
it's about all countries changing their
mindset and
welcoming them until then they're
determined to push their way in any way
they can
Natasha guy named Al Jazira Dayron on
the border between Turkey and Greece